Hey!  How's it going bro's? My name is Pewdiepie.
We're gonna play--keep playing some Uncharted 4
We just uncovered all of these dead pirates
There's
Oh Hello
A journal.
Okay.What did you draw for us?
That is hilarious.
Honor among theives...
Alright...
This guy is bald.
That's weird.
Cause Nate has the greatest hair cut of all time..
Next time I get a haircut-I'm gonna go into the barber shop and be like give me the Nate.
Hit me up with the Nate Bro.
Don't know what I'm taking about.
I'm sure of it.
Oh boy-We're near the end of this epic tale.
Epic-Epic being an understatement.
Cause Holy Sh*t this game is amazing.
I've been raving on about it for I don't know how many hours now
UH-AH there goes the family
No more Drake's in this family
I love this part.
Where they use these walls or whatever
But I don't need them apparently. wtf.
I'll meet you at top.
Ha.
So Flirtatious
ohh..hey Nate.That's for later man...
Not cool
Don't
Don't do that sh*t.
Well you got to appreciate the view.
Sorry...what?
Could be people there.
Alright...what do we got down here?
Yup. We're f*cked.
How the f*ck are we gonna get across?
Are you for reals with me right now?
Ooh-This way.
Got it.
Hey-We didn't even go in here.
Although there seems to be something here-I gotta check it out
No...I got it -Thank-you.
Hey-an elephant. Why not? You know what? Why not?
Why not?
Cool-Finally.
Jesus Christ-We've gone so many different plac-
We've been in Scotland,Africa,uh Italy.
Where were we before that? I don't even remember.
Islands
Ha-ha
Oh-Are you gonna play?
Probably out of tune
Pretty piano though.
Macho Nacho.
This house is
Macho um Pac-F*ck you
Oh God.
Hey maybe I was supposed to do that.
Who knows.
Cozy kitchen.
Got a great view here from the kitchen.
Wait, what?
Ooh my god!
Kill me please im an idiot!
Why do i keep doing that?
I've done that so many times, man
I am sorry.
Please keep watching, im trying my best.
I came  from here.
I got braindamage from all the let's plays
Im sorry.
This is where we wanna go.
Hi guys.
Pretty cool place you got here.
I'll take this
And we gonna shoot everyone in the ass.
Bitch.
What do you mean "hmm"?
Oh there's gonna be a fight here soon
More footprints...dont call-
Pfff
"Don't even joke about pirate gho"
Are these the footprints?
Ohh, okay we're following them
Well I hope Sam is still alive
You know someone is gonna die
Cause it's the end of a big series
You know what I mean
Im thinking Sam is going to die, but he already once,
so it is kinda... like weird. You know what I mean?
Why do I keep saying "You know what I mean?" You know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Cant stop saying
Im fine, thank for asking
I cant tell the difference between the guns
like
Yeah this is a good gun
Alright.
I suppose we climb
Im sure they took the same route...
They seemed to be good climbers
Hey babe, how are ya doing?
Ah, dont worry about me now, I know what Im doin'
Eh
Ergh
Where?
There?
How the f*ck did you get there you crazy son of
Ah, come on
Alright, uh... excuse me
I don't know what I'm doing
How did you get there?
Oh, my Lord!
Hey babe.
Let's go!
surely they're hearing this- never mind
Hey baby
Thought I hand granades
F*ck ther's a lot of them
F*cking mass murder happening here
Almost shot my wife, Jesus
Nice!
Shot my wife.
Alright, alright, alright!
F*cking epic music
I love this sh*t!
Where d' they go?
Hey!
Could kill someone
Wtf! Where do you come from!?
Oh god
Ooooh!
You just got Ethan Bradberried, b*tch!
That's what I'm taking about!
Oh sh*t.
Who shot that?
Oooooh!
f*ck yeah!
I think we did it.
That was fun.
Well, maybe it was just trapped
Who are you swinging at?
Oh, nice teleportation skills
Good thing they can't aim
Hey buddy! How you doin'?
Did he kill him, too?
That's not a bad hallway, man!
That's crazy.
f*cking Avery is... insane.
What up, what up, what up?
damn, not a bad place, dude
Is that a f*cking Ti-, okay.
Alright.
I've seen it all.
Is that him?
Man, what a player.
What a pimpedypimpedy pimp!
What a pimpedy poop
Alright, there is gotta be a hidden thing
The footprints
They literally disappear here
That's kinda weird, isn't it?
Why would they just...
go away like that?
right?
He framed in like
super
someone wrote all that
but where do we- oh!
I don't think so
so smart
Nate is over the Treasures,
he just wants his brother back
but I suppose
It's their mothers epic quest, you know?
Ah.. we're f*cked now
3 more chapters... godammit
What do we got here?
Hey rats, how you doin'?
What?
Why are they doing that now?
game keeps surprising you
got the booty
well then, never mind
Where do we go then?
I don't know.
Here?
Sh*******t
piece of sh*t lighter
How the f*ck did you come up there?
Whoa, that weirded me out, man
What is happening right now?
Where?
That's better.
Ok this is a lot nicer
holy sh*t!
Can we go through here?
no.
I mean we're literally stuck
unless...
no.
Okay there it is.
sure, no problem
This is creepy, man
I dont like this
It scares me
Aand we made it through.
holy sh*t!
Hey, a foot!
I dodged that one, too.
Why do they keep- FEET!
Hi guys.
Oh god
I'm just thinking we could be trapped here s easily, forever
makes me anxious as f*ck
hi guys
"The heart that hardened against me"
F*ck you.
Just great, just great!
Where do we go then?
What ' I say?
stop!
Down we go
Yeah, totally
This looks like something
a flare!
They're so cute
neither did we, Nate!
Oh it's coming
They're waiting for us
Jesus christ, man!
Everyone just calm down, alright?
nice
Jesus Christ!
Oh, here is this guy
f*ck me
come on
That's good, that's good man.
Oh sh*t!
thank you!
Oh god, there's more.
no more, please!
Oh there is definitely gonna be more.
who?
Oh, that guy.
Thanks for the help
Why-Why would he- I shot his head like a million times!
There it is.
or that
"The mouth that spoke ill-"
dude you're f*cking insane.
aha
Nate always knows what to say.
we might be ahead of them now
pffft
awkward...
so, where do we go then?
here?
back up?
what's that?
another letter
a key
Avery's kinda key
and a cLUE
alright!
let's go find... a keeeey hole
don't explode please for the love of god
well y'know what? fuck
ahh
son of a bitch
oh mai goddd
fuck you!
don't explode
oh my god
ah jesus
ah my
oh my god
ahh
ah jeez
aHHH
ahh
aHh nAH
ahh shit!
fuck
god please
make it STAHP
pffft
don't explode
we got a baby
wiggle
nice.. my favorite
love to play that.
they.. they wiggle
hUEH
*slightly giggles*
aaand this time we don't have help
but we have the thing
that's an empty page..
here we go
ok so in Avery's
in the right corner
both is top
mmm ok
can't walk anywhere there
maybe, we can walk through here
OH WAIT
IT'S UPSIDE DOWN
ok..uhh
we CAN walk here
Avery said we can walk through here
uhhh
boat was on top? ( idk if he said boat or both)
right? sorry.
AHH SHUT UP!!
ok I see how it works
yeah
we can walk here
and then we can walk here
and then we can't walk there..
but.. we can walk...
uhhh
nowhere here
fuck
suppose we can walk
here..
ya! STUPID AVERY
MORE LIKE.. BABERY
AHHHH shit
got'em
yes
ahh fuck the flare
aHHH FRESH AIR
no more exploding mummies puhlease
we found a key hole guys!!
alright alright alright
oh my..THE KEY! PLEASE
for the love of god
why would this one be a trap?
I suppose because there's..
traps everywhere...
ooo (sexual poods needs to stop)
uh oh (NO SHIT)
is it me or is it getting hot in here??
oh god
we're running OUTTA TIME!!
but.. we're still cozy in here
there we go
dude, that was like, your only chance to get outta here man
are you ser-
fucking iofbsogg (idk what he said lol)
ok well i guess we're gonna die
are you fucking kidding me right now??
well... its time to start cutting
C'MONNNN
RUNN BITCH RUNN
OOOOHHHH
fUCK ME MAN
ARE YOU SERIOUS RIGHT NOW???
I'M SO SICK OF THESE FUCKING EXPLODING MUMMIES!!
GOD!
FUCKING
DAMN IT!
HOW MANY DID HE PUT???
are we gonna check if she's okay?? maybe??
ahh she's dead
THAT IS SEW KEYUUTE
god damn explosions
gahhh so close
keep going then i guess
now we know what their reward is
two more chapters
technically three actually
mmm more climbing why not?
y'know what? WHY NOT?
what's stopping us at this point?
y'know what i mean?
oooo i love these
hEPH
pLAH
HOOLY SHIT
dude
we could've just gone here right away
could've told me
just..
just go around the alley and you'll find it
oh my god what the..
lotta boats here
well then..
its never safe around Nathan Drake
i live by the danger
fuck yeah bitch
this is too easy
OOOO FUCK YEAH THAT WAS COOL
look sam he's getting sprayed by machine guns
alright, my turn
ah come on
where?
jesus
guys
come on gimme the sniper
I'M NATHAN DRAKE BITCH!
IM NATHAN BRADBERRY MOTHERFUCKER (idk if this is what he said)
that's one way to do it I suppose
JESUS CHRIST
that was close
who's left??
ah shit you fucking aim me god damn it
got'em
fuck. i ran outta ammo
i'll get this one
got'em
shit
OH SHIT that was fucking close
oh fuck me (ok :) )
that was sexy as shit
oh god
ummm
that one
show me ur titties
thank you
kickin' some sweet ass over here guys
of course there's more of them
JEESUS
don't do that
shot'em in the ass
always does the trick
alright, who's next?
you are
like this guys
ayyy we did it!
fucking hell
lotta squeezing in this game guys..
lottaaaa squeezing
i don't know how to feel about it